dass wir schauen können auf den nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt das ist der Top 8 in
dieser Sitzungswoche vereinbarte Debatte
das heißt alle Fraktionen haben sich
darüber darauf verständigt diesen
Tagesordnungspunkt zu setzen es gibt
auch keine Vorlagen also keine Anträge
dazu und es geht um den Internationalen
Frauentag am 8 März traditionell wird
über diesen Frauentag diskutiert in der
Woche zuvor im Parlament so an den noch
im Vorfeld zu diskutieren der
Hintergrund ist klar wir Frauen
verdienen laut Statistischen Bundesamt
im Schnitt rund 18% weniger als Männer
investieren seltener an der Börse heißt
es und sind die Hauptbetroffenen von
Altersarmut da ist also einiges nach wie
vor im Argen auf der anderen Seite so
hat es abends die Kollegen vom
Handelsblatt dieser Tage festgestellt
die im vergangenen Jahr eingeführte
Frauenquote für Vorstände die zeigt
Wirkung 42% aller Neubesetzungen der Top
Positionen der Dax-Konzerne im
vergangenen Jahr waren weiblich der
Frauenanteil im deutschen Leitindex
stieg damit von Komma drei auf 19,1% das
sei so heißt es ein Rekordzuwachs auf
der anderen Seite noch ein Negativ Punkt
Frauen profitieren weniger von Pandemie
Hilfspaketen als Männer also auch da
sieht man wieder mit der
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit sind ist es
noch nicht so weit her wie es eigentlich
sein sollte und das wird zentrales Thema
eben sein dieser Debatte die jetzt
gleich beginnt erste Rednerin wird sein
die Bundesministerin für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend eine Spiegel
über alle anderen und jetzt schaut
katrin Göring-Eckardt noch mal auf die
Abgeordneten das ist ja üblich im
Parlament dass es eine kleine Rotation
gibt wenn das Thema wechselt also alle
die sich hier überwiegend mit
Außenpolitik beschäftigen oder
Verteidigungspolitik oder
Angelegenheiten der Europäischen Union
davon verlassen jetzt einige das Plenum
und es kommt in der Tat immer eher die
die sich mit diesem Themenfeld hier
beschäftigen interessante einige
Minister da Hubertus Heil dem
bundesarbeits- und Sozialminister sehen
wir auch die innen bundesinnenministerin
da und natürlich jetzt am Pult eine
Spiegel die Familienministerin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren Abgeordnete
sehr geehrte zuhörende wir sind mit der
Plenardebatte zum Internationalen
Frauentag einerseits früh dran denn er
ist erst in 19 Tagen und das Motto am 8
März lautet ich for equal jede und jeder
für Gleichberechtigung und da frage ich
mich andererseits natürlich warum wir so
spät dran sind warum Frauen nach mehr
als 100 Jahren Frauentag noch immer
nicht gleichberechtigt und
gleichgestellt sind und warum wir viel
mehr erst einen Tag vorher am 7 märz den
Equal Pay Day haben
mit dem wir weltweit darauf aufmerksam
machen dass Frauen 2022
weltweit statistisch 65 Tage umsonst
arbeiten müssen weil sie im Schnitt 19%
niedrigere Stundenlöhne haben als Männer
und in Deutschland stehen wir mit 18%
nicht viel besser da und das
Weltwirtschaftsforum hat vorgerechnet
dass wir Gleichstellung erst in 135
Jahren erreichen wenn wir mit diesem
Tempo weitermachen und wir wollen nicht
so weitermachen Frau Ministerin möchten
Sie eine Zwischenfrage von Frau von
Storch zulassen
ja
bitte sehr
[Applaus]
ja vielen herzlichen Dank tatsächlich
dass sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen und
sie ist auch sehr kurz ich würde gerne
von Ihnen wissen weil sie gerade gesagt
haben die Gleichberechtigung der Frauen
sein nicht erreicht welche Rechte Rechte
haben Frauen in Deutschland nicht die
Männer haben ganz konkret welches Recht
haben wir nicht was die Männer haben
nicht die Gleichstellung die
Gleichberechtigung
sehr geehrter Abgeordnete ich bin ja
eben in meiner Rede bereits drauf
eingegangen ich möchte das auch gerne
noch im weiteren Verlauf meiner Rede
weiter ausführen meines Erachtens sollte
jede Frau in der Bundesrepublik das
Recht haben auf gleiche Bezahlung mit
den Männern das heißt für gleiche Arbeit
muss es gleiche Bezahlung geben und
dieses Recht ist nach wie vor in der
Bundesrepublik nicht verwirklicht und
genau daran müssen wir weiter arbeiten
und deshalb meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren Abgeordnete und Liebe
zuhörende sollten wir so nicht
weitermachen wir sollten nicht weiter
unter unseren Möglichkeiten bleiben
dennoch nie hatten wir eine besser
ausgebildete Frauengeneration als heute
gebildet qualifiziert und hochmotiviert
und wir sollten dafür sorgen dass diese
Frauen Generation sich genauso
einbringen kann wie die Männer bleiben
wir
bleiben wir also als Land nicht weiter
unseren ökonomischen unter unseren
kreativen und unter unseren politischen
Möglichkeiten sondern schöpfen wir unser
Potenzial aus jede und jeder nach Talent
und Zeit Frauen und Männer auf Augenhöhe
egal ob mit oder ohne
Migrationshintergrund ob mit oder ohne
Behinderung das ist mein Verständnis von
Intersektionalität und Feminismus und
das ist es auf den Punkt gebracht doch
was Gleichberechtigung und
Gleichstellung bedeuten und dazu gehört
dazu gehört selbstverständlich dass
Frauen zur Hälfte an allen relevanten
Entscheidungen beteiligt werden und dass
sie genauso viel Einkommen erzielen
können wie Männer und darum bringen wir
mehr Frauen in Führungsposition darum
werden wir das Entgelt Transparenzgesetz
überarbeiten und darum werden wir auch
Familien unterstützen unbezahlte Arbeit
im Haushalt mit Kindern und in der
Pflege partnerschaftlich auf mehreren
Schultern zu verteilen und darum werden
wir auch den Kampf gegen Armut von
Frauen insbesondere gegen Altersarmut
aufnehmen in dieser Gesellschaft
und diese Themen wollen wir auch in
Europa setzen damit auch Europa nicht
unter seinen Möglichkeiten bleibt wir
beenden die Blockade bei der
Führungsposition Richtlinie wir werden
die
lohntransparenzrichtlinie aktiv
unterstützen und wenn die Kommission
demnächst eine europäische Strategie für
Pflege und Betreuung vorliegt dann sind
wir gut vorbereitet denn
Gleichberechtigung macht Europa stark
und es ist übrigens kein Zufall dass das
Auto geraten sind die das Rad
zurückdrehen wollen in demokratischen in
starken und in gleichberechtigten
Gesellschaften hätten sie keine Chance
wir in Deutschland haben den
gleichstellungsscheck vereinbart dem
sich alle Vorhaben unterziehen müssen
und so haben wir gute Chancen das
Gesetze dazu beitragen die Potenziale
von Frauen und Männern gleichermaßen zu
heben und ihren Bedürfnissen
gleichermaßen gerecht zu werden aber
lassen Sie mich den Blick auf ein nach
wie vor großes Problem in unserer
Gesellschaft lenken und das ist die
alltägliche Gewalt gegen Frauen und
Mädchen und unsere Gesellschaft Gewalt
die Frauen in ihren Grundrechten auf
Leben Freiheit und Gesundheit massiv
beschränkt und die gesellschaftliche
Teilhabe die gesellschaftliche Teilhabe
verhindert und es macht fassungslos dass
in Deutschland an jedem dritten Tag eine
Frau von ihrem Partner oder Ex-Partner
getötet wird aber es macht uns nicht
tatenlos denn wir wollen das Hilfesystem
verbessern und das Recht auf Schutz vor
Gewalt für jede Frau und ihre Kinder ab
und ein bundeseinheitlichen Rechtsrahmen
für eine verlässliche Finanzierung von
Frauenhäusern sicherstellen
meine Damen und Herren liebe zuhören der
es ist allerhöchste Zeit für
Gleichstellung und ich werde als
Frauenministerin dafür kämpfen dass
Deutschland nicht unter seinen
Möglichkeiten bleiben aber getreudes
Mottos dass wir jede und jeden brauchen
keine Frauenministerin kein
Frauenministerium schafft das alleine
und deshalb möchte ich an dieser Stelle
auch all jenen danken die sich
tagtäglich hier in diesem Hohen Hause
aber auch in der ganzen Bundesrepublik
für Frauenrechte und für
Gleichberechtigung stark machen denn nur
zusammen werden wir dieses Ziel
erreichen herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
die Kollegin Mareike Lotte Wolf hat
jetzt das Wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion
und zu ihrer ersten Rede
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich freue mich
erstmal sehr dass das Präsidium sich
entschieden hat diese Debatte auf den
Geburtstag von Rita Süßmuth zu legen der
ist an dieser Stelle ganz herzlich
gratulieren möchte die sicherlich auch
viel für Frauen in diesem Land getan hat
und so viele Frauen Vorbild war
liebe Frau Ministerin vielen Dank für
Ihre Rede ich muss Ihnen aber eines
sagen bei vielen Themen stimmen wir
überein bei vielen Themen hätte ich mir
aber auch gewünscht ein bisschen mehr
als wohlwollende Appelle und Ankündigung
ein bisschen mehr konkretes das haben
die Frauen in diesem Land verdient meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
ein bisschen mehr konkretes weil wir
ganz konkret darauf schauen müssen wie
geht es Frauen in diesem Land in dieser
Zeit und ich möchte sagen Corona ist
eine Krise der Frauen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren Frauen
Schultern im Gesundheitswesen eine
Hauptlast der Pandemie Frauen haben im
Lockdown die Versorgung von Kindern und
Homeoffice übernommen sie sind und sie
waren im Grundschulen und in den Kitas
dem Virus besonders ausgesetzt und das
ist nicht nur ein Anlass Danke zu sagen
das ist ein Anlass mal ganz konkret
hinzuschauen wie geht es Frauen in den
Berufen die dir sogenannten Frauenberufe
und ich finde im Bereich Pflege da hat
sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten einiges
getan der ein oder andere wird sagen
vielleicht nicht genug aber es gibt
einen Bereich den mangelberuf der
Erzieherin indem wir uns in diesem Land
aus meiner Sicht unhaltbare Zustände
leisten in diesem Beruf sind 90% Frauen
und ich glaube es gibt keine deutsche
Stadt oder Gemeinde die nicht nach
Erzieherinnen Händeringen sucht aber wir
bilden hier weiterhin voll schulisch aus
und das heißt am Ende nichts anderes
dass wir her Scharen von unbezahlten
Praktikantin in den Kitas als billiger
Aushilfskräfte haben und einige von
denen du dich kenne auch einige von
denen arbeiten dann am Wochenende im
Supermarkt um sich ihre Ausbildung
leisten zu können und deshalb wird es
endlich Zeit die Erzieherausbildung und
die Sozialassistenten Ausbildung
flächendeckend zu vergüten und Frau
Spiegel sie haben da eine Initiative
angekündigt aber wir werden Sie an den
Ergebnissen messen ob am Ende der Bund
die Länder zielgerichtet unterstützt
hier eine tarifliche Bezahlung zu
gewährleisten
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren die
corona-krise ist eine Krise der Frauen
denn Arbeitsplätze von Frauen sind
betroffen und sie sind auch gefährdet
anders als in anderen Krisen die
corona-krise hat einen Zehnjährigen
Aufbau von Arbeitsplätzen abrupt beendet
und von diesem Aufbau von Arbeitsplätzen
haben insbesondere die Frauen profitiert
in diesem Land denn ihr
Beschäftigungsgrad der ist
kontinuierlich angestiegen
von Corona sind erstmalig nicht nur die
Bereiche der Industrie betroffen sondern
auch die Bereiche der Dienstleistungen
dem Frauen vornehmlich tätig sind z.B
der Handel die Touristik die
Messewirtschaft die Gastronomie die
Friseure aber auch der gesamte Bereich
der Freizeit und wenn sich die Industrie
mittlerweile langsam wiederholt sehen
und sagen und sehen sich die
Dienstleistung weiterhin Beschränkungen
ausgesetzt und wenn wir im Herbst eine
erneute Welle bekommen dann werden das
auch die Bereiche sein die als erstes
wieder reguliert werden und deshalb
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
finde ich muss man solche sozialen
Maßnahmen wie die Erhöhung des
Mindestlohns eben relativ sehen wenn es
um Frauen geht denn zur Wahrheit gehört
auch dazu dass Frauen von einer guten
Konjunktur und von besser bezahlten Jobs
am meisten profitieren und deshalb
werden wir diese Regierung daran messen
wie schnell sie Beschäftigung für Frauen
wieder aufbauen wie schnell sie gute
hochwertige
sozialversicherungspflichtige Jobs und
gerne auf tariflich vergütete Jobs für
Frauen schaffen und die Vereinbarkeit
von Familie und Beruf stärken
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
Corona ist eine Krise der Frauen denn
ein sehr schweres Kapitel ist der
Anstieg der sexualisierten Gewalt gegen
Kinder vornehmlich viele Mädchen im Jahr
2020 also im Jahr des lockdowns ist die
Verbreitung und der Konsum von
missbrauchsabbildung oder besser gesagt
sexualisierter Folter gegen Kinder um
mehr als 50% gestiegen und wo
Abbildungen sind da sind Taten und ich
glaube wir müssen alle rechtsstaatlichen
Mittel nutzen um diese Zustände zu
bekämpfen
und lassen Sie mich sagen vor diesem
Hintergrund ist die gezielte
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ein wirklich
wichtiges Mittel und es ist fahrlässig
sich dem zu verweigern
und deshalb liebe Frau Spiegel machen
Sie nicht nur eine Kampfansage gegen
Kinderarmut machen Sie nicht nur eine
Kampfansage gegen Einsamkeit im Alter
dies ist eben gemacht haben machen sie
auch eine Kampfansage gegen
Kindesmissbrauch und überzeugen Sie
Ihren Kollegen Herrn Buschmann die
sexualisierte Folter von Kindern im Netz
zu bekämpfen und die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung zur
Missbrauchsbekämpfung möglich Punkt
die Kinder in diesem Land werden sie es
werden es Ihnen danken meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam für die Gleichberechtigung von
Männern und Frauen einstehen und
gemeinsam für die Rechte von Frauen
mutig eintreten ich danke Ihnen für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Mareike lotte-wohl war das aus der
Unionsfraktion die zu Beginn ihrer Rede
mit einer sehr schönen Geste wie ich
finde noch mal Rita süßmut zum 85
Geburtstag gratuliert hat der nämlich
heute ist die Person schmut war ja von
88 bis 98 Präsidentin des Deutschen
Bundestags davor zwei Jahre
Bundesfamilienministerin und sie war am
vergangenen Sonntag Mitglied der
Bundesversammlung die Frank-Walter
Steinmeier im Amt als Bundespräsident
bestätigt hat und noch eine erste Rede
und zwar von Ariane Fischer aus der
SPD-Fraktion liebe Kinder liebe Menschen
break the buyers brechen wir die
Voreingenommenheit so lautet das Motto
des diesjährigen Internationalen
Frauentages er fußt auf dem Kampf der
Frauen für ihr Wahlrecht die Feministin
Clara gehen forderte damals keine
Sonderrechte sondern Menschenrechte für
Frauen das war 1908 und heute
wie 1908 wir fordern die Hälfte des
Geldes wir fordern die Hälfte der macht
noch immer sitzen in deutschen
Vorständen mehr Männer mit dem Namen
Thomas als Frauen noch immer
verdienen Frauen weniger
ungefähr 20% weniger als Männer mit dem
Mindestlohn werden wir ab Oktober
endlich ein entscheidenden Schritt
weiterkommen dieses Verhältnis
anzugleichen und auch Altersarmut
wirksam bekämpfen können
wir Frauen wollen euch liebe Männer
liebe Kollegen aber gar keine Rechte
wegnehmen wir wollen nur umgekehrt das
männlich sein nicht mehr automatisch
privilegiert ist
was wir Liebe Mitstreiter innen hingegen
nicht unterschätzen dürfen das ist die
gefühlte Bedrohung die davon ausgeht 50%
der Macht abzugeben macht sich hat
Kontrolle und Überlegenheit das
Gegenteil von macht ist Ohnmacht und ihr
häufigstes Gegenmittel ist Gewalt
daher durchzieht Gewalt die oft
struktureller Natur ist in unendlich
vielen Spielarten die allermeisten
Frauen leben von Kindheit an sexueller
Missbrauch weibliche
Genitalverstümmelung
diskriminierende Sprache die Frauen zum
Objekt macht Stalking verschiedenste
Formen sexueller Gewalt bis hin zum Mord
in der Pandemie wurde mehr als jede
zehnte Frau von ihrem Partner bedroht
geschlagen und vergewaltigt die Zahlen
korrelieren mit den Finanzsorgen
Ängsten und Depressionen ihrer Männer
Frauen mit Behinderung sind noch zwei
bis dreimal häufiger von sexualisierter
Gewalt betroffen als andere Frauen und
hier geht es nicht um Lust es geht um
Dominanz
alle zwei bis drei Tage Frau Spiegel hat
das bereits erwähnt wird in Deutschland
eine Frau von ihrem Partner oder
Ex-Partner getötet Richter nennen das
meistens eine Beziehungstat und deswegen
maximal Totschlag
Feministin nennen es femizid
aber was können wir tun
Strafrecht kann das Problem nicht lösen
denn egal welche Strafe ein Täter
bekommt das Opfer hat bereits
lebenslänglich
im Koalitionsvertrag haben wir nach der
istanbelt istanbul-konvention den
Anspruch auf Schutz für jede Frau
formuliert das ist richtig und gut
allerdings stehen den empfohlenen 21.400
Plätze in Frauenhäusern heute faktisch
nur 6800 existierende Plätze gegenüber
unsere Strategie besteht also momentan
wesentlich darin Hilfe Strukturen für
Opfer auszubauen aber das ist der
gleiche unglaublich teure und oftmals
leider nur sehr begrenzt funktionierende
Reparaturbetrieb den wir uns im
Gesundheitswesen im Strafvollzug und in
der Jugendhilfe leisten
der beste Opferschutz ist daher
Prävention sorgen wir dafür dass niemand
mehr aus Hilflosigkeit oder aus Angst
zum Täter werden muss das erreichen wir
durch niedrigschwellige gesprächs- und
Therapieangebote die dabei helfen die
eigene Ohnmacht in gestaltende Kraft zu
übersetzen und durch ein Männerbild dass
sie Auseinandersetzung mit Ängsten und
Gefühlen als Stärke und nicht als
Schwäche interpretiert
begleiten wir zudem die Kinder ab der
Kita beim Gesunden groß werden auch
emotional indem wir Psychologen und
Sozialpädagogen fest in pädagogischen
Teams verankern und diese die Nöte der
Kinder ach als die Nöte der Familien
betrachten und daran arbeiten
eine talentorientierte Bildung würde
Menschen zudem ihre Stärken entwickeln
lassen damit sie sich selbstwirksam
fähig und zukunftsfest fühlen können das
würde auch die gesellschaftliche
Resilienz erhöhen und Menschen weniger
anfällig für Angst verschwörungsmythen
Hass und Gewalt machen
Albert Einstein sagte man kann ein
Problem nicht aus dem Geist Herauslösen
der es geschaffen hat
deswegen ist es Zeit für eine
weiblichere Weltsicht es ist Zeit auch
hier mehr Fortschritt zu wagen
es ist zeit für Liebe und Empathie als
Kernkompetenzen für eine menschlichere
Gewalt menschlichere Welt ohne Gewalt es
ist Zeit für neue Geschlechterrollen ich
bin für Frauen die alles können und
dürfen und für Männer die nicht alles
können müssen ich bin für Menschen die
einfach einzigartig anders sein dürfen
denn Frauenrechte sind Menschenrechte
Break device
Ariane Fischer war das aus der
SPD-Fraktion und wir sehen schon wenn
wir mal auf unsere Vorschau gucken
überwiegend Frauen in dieser Debatte
einen Mann kann ich gerade ausmachen
Erik von malottki der später noch
spricht
das im Grundsatz dass sie ihre Redezeit
schon eine Weile überschritten haben und
das geht immer beim ersten Mal über die
nächsten Mal werden wir dann hier
strenger als Präsidium jetzt hat das
Wort die Kollegin Marianne haderkönig
für die AFD trotzdem
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren als vor 111
Jahren der Weltfrauentag eingeführt
wurde da ging es Frauen noch um die
echten Frauenrechte nämlich in guten und
richtigen Kampf für die
Gleichberechtigung und für die Freiheit
der Frau heute werden vor allem Phantom
Debatten geführt da geht es um die
gendergerechte Verhunzung der deutschen
Sprache oder immer wieder über das
leidige Thema Frauenquote ein Blick auf
die Regierungsbank reicht um zu sehen
welche Folge diese Quote hat eine
Außenministerin eine Außenministerin die
von feministischer
außenpolitikspatroniert was bitte soll
das sein Frau Berber wollen sie Tampons
über Teheran abwerfen
[Applaus]
die die Familie abschaffen und durch
eine Verantwortungsgemeinschaft ersetzen
will künftig wird es möglich sein dass
ein Kind ein Vater und drei Mütter hat
damit wird die für Frauen katastrophale
islamische viel eher in Deutschland de
facto legalisiert unfassbar Frau Spiegel
und sie alle sie alle haben eines
gemeinsam Frauen dazu Opfern wo sie gar
keine sind und sie schweigen trönt laut
dort wo Frauen zunehmend zu opfern
werden Gender und Sinn und wir
beauftragte werden eben nicht den über
100.000 Frauen helfen die Opfer
häuslicher Gewalt sind und Sie werden
ebenso wenig den Frauen helfen die von
Zwangsverheiratung Ehrenmorden und
sexuellen Übergriffen bedroht wird all
das passiert aber in angeblich besten
Deutschland das ist je gab und durch ihr
politisch korrektes
kultursensibles Schweigen machen sie
sich mitschuldig mitschuldig daran dass
die über Jahrhunderte hart erkämpften
Rechte der Frauen und Freiheiten der
Frauen verloren gehen
deshalb
ist es erforderlich eine ganz neue
Debatte über Frauenrechte zu führen aber
die muss verdammt noch mal ehrlich sein
Frauenrechte zu stärken ist aktuell
wichtiger denn je aber dabei geht es
eben nicht um gender waren oder darum
wie man seine Eltern politisch korrekt
benennt sondern es geht darum dass wir
Frauen uns in Deutschland das 21
jahrhunderts die Freiheit
zurückerkämpfen müssen angstfrei und
ohne männliche Begleitung nachts auf die
Straße gehen zu können es geht um die
Freiheit sich seinen Ehemann selber
aussuchen zu dürfen in nicht mit X
anderen Frauen teilen zu müssen oder
schon als Kind zwangsverheiratet zu
werden es geht um die Freiheit sicher
als Frauen Mutter auch für drei Kinder
und mehr entscheiden zu können ohne sich
dem Risiko von Altersarmut auszusetzen
oder sich von kinderlosen Grünen als CO2
produzieren das Heimchen am Herd
beschimpfen zu lassen
und vor allem geht es um Nulltoleranz
null Toleranz bei der zunehmenden Gewalt
gegen Frauen egal ob es sich um sexuelle
oder häusliche Gewalt um
Zwangsverheiratung genitalverstümmung
oder Kinder in handelt statt sich aber
um diese echten Probleme zu kümmern
wollen sie eine Art Neues materialchat
einführen ein materialchat das so
kultursensibel sowok so voller
selbstfass ist dass es ein scharfen
Kulturen auf der ganzen Welt die Tore
öffnet
wundern sie sich aber nicht wenn ihre
Material hat plötzlich in einem
Patriarchat ganz neue Qualität aufwacht
dieses wird allerdings nicht so bunt und
wog sein sondern vermutlich Burka
schwarz daher
daher meiner Pell an sie erinnern sich
an die Anfängen des Weltfrauentag ist
der den guten und richtigen Kampf echter
frauenkämpferin und an der Folge dieses
Kampfes Freiheit Gleichberechtigung
Schutz vor Gewalt Massenmigration ist
aus archerischen Kulturkreisen und der
Kampf für diese Rechte sind schlicht
inkompatibel also beenden Sie die
Massenmigration beenden Sie Ihren
konstruierten Kampf der Geschlechter
lassen sie Leistung und Qualifikation
entscheiden keine Quote dann und nur
dann werden sie der einzigen
aufgabegerecht die Sie in diesem Hause
haben nämlich dem Wohl des deutschen
Volkes zu dienen und zwar des ganzen
Volkes der Frauen wie der Männer vielen
Dank
diskutiert über den Internationalen
Frauentag und was ist noch an Defiziten
gibt in der Gleichstellung von Frauen
mit Männern und in dieser Debatte wird
die nächste Rennen Nicole Bauer sein aus
der FDP-Fraktion während des da im
Hintergrund noch einiges an Unruhe gibt
sind wir auch immer als Mitglieder der
Bundesversammlung diffamiert worden ich
rate Ihnen über diese Diffamierung noch
mal nachzudenken wenn ich das richtig
gehört habe jetzt gebe ich das Wort der
Kunde nach gelber Karte angehört mal
gucken ob es da noch ein Nachspiel
zugibt wir haben ja Zwischenruf leider
nicht verstanden und können deswegen
dazu auch nichts sagen aber die
Bundestags ist Vizepräsidentin hat wohl
genauer hingehört jetzt Nicole Bauer
FDP-Fraktion Sprecherin für
Frauenpolitik und diversity oder
Diversität geht auch Zeit voraus wenn
wir heute über den Internationalen
Frauentag am 8 März bereits sprechen
unserer Zeit voraus ich wünschte ich
könnte das auch über die gelebte echte
Gleichberechtigung Deutschland sagen
aber da war leider doch 16 Jahre
unionsgeprägter Regierung und trotz
einer Kanzlerin nicht möglich meine
Damen und Herren
doch Dinge ändern sich zum Glück und so
auf die Regierungskonstellation in
unserem Land und in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag haben wir eine klare
Ausrichtung in Richtung moderne
Gesellschaftspolitik und als Ampeln
setzen wir die Segel neu in Richtung
Aufbruch in Richtung Modernisierung wir
verstehen uns als eine echte
fortschrittskoalition wir wollen
Veränderung und wir machen progressive
Politik
damit die Menschen in allen Lebenslagen
egal in welchem geschlechtsspferde
verwirklichen Chancen haben denn darauf
kommt es an liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir werden Menschen
insbesondere Frauen im digitalen Raum
und in der realen Welt stärker von
Gewalt schützen denn nur ein
gewaltfreies Leben ist die Grundlage für
eine frei Entfaltung dafür wollen wir
die istanbul-konvention vorbehaltlos
umsetzen
denn es ist nur die Spitze des Eisberge
das an jedem dritten Tag eine Frau von
ihrem Partner oder Ex-Partner getötet
wird hier in Deutschland mitten in
unserer Gesellschaft und alle 45 Minuten
muss die Polizei ausrücken gegen
häusliche Gewalt und wem das schon viel
genug erscheint dem möchte ich zurufen
nein es fängt viel früher an es fängt
bei der respektvollen Begegnung auf
Augenhöhe an denn sexistischen
Kommentaren und Belästigungen leider
müssen wir das jetzt hier im Parlament
immer wieder erleben dass der Respekt
nicht für alle eine
Selbstverständlichkeit und das sage ich
ausgerechnet in ihre Fraktion
vier Frauen bin und jetzt haben sie eben
gezeigt es rückwärts gewandt und alles
andere was die Frauen wollen oder Frauen
brauchen sie brauchen nämlich Freiheit
ihre eigenen Entscheidungen treffen zu
können sich nach den eigenen
Vorstellungen entwickeln zu können ob
sie im sozialen Bereich eine Pflegekraft
oder Ärztin sein will eine Firma gründen
möchte oder ein künstliche Intelligenz
forschen möchte ob sie dabei aufsteigen
und Führungsverantwortung übernehmen
will oder ob sie das Familienleben wie
sie das vereinbaren möchte mit Ihrem
Partner oder Ihrer Partnerin und
schließlich ob sie überhaupt Kinder will
im Ausnahmefall einer ungewollten
Schwangerschaft muss das auch bedeuten
dass Frauen und Paare den möglichst
niedrigschwellen Zugang zu seriösen
Informationen aus medizinischer Hand hat
und genau deshalb streichen wir 219a
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verantwortungsvolle und mündige
Entscheidung kann eine Frau nur dann
treffen wenn wir es dir auch zutrauen
also trauen wir den Frauen in unserem
Land mehr zu und schaffen wir Pferde
Chancen für unabhängig vom Geschlecht
für eine gelebte Gleichberechtigung für
individuelle Verwirklichung ein
gewaltfreies und selbstbestimmtes Leben
finanzielle Unabhängigkeit die
Möglichkeit in der Zukunft mitgestalten
zu können also schaffen wir faire
Chancen für gelebte Gleichberechtigung
ja das ist die Debatte zum Weltfrauentag
aber doch wissen wir längst dass es dazu
auch Männer braucht die erkennen was sie
dabei gewinnen können Artikel 3 ist ein
ständiger Auftrag in diesem Sinne
wünsche ich Ihnen allen einen schönen
Weltfrauentag
[Applaus]
jetzt hat die Kollegin halt die
Reicheneck das Wort für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen ich erinnere mich sehr gerne
an die Wurzeln des Internationalen
Frauentages der entstand nämlich auf
Initiative sozialistischer Feministinnen
ich finde das kann man hier durchaus mal
erwähnen und zwar schon vor dem Ersten
Weltkrieg mit dem Ziel für
Gleichberechtigung und Gleichstellung
der Frauen zu kämpfen über 100 Jahre
also mit Unterbrechung in der Zeit des
Faschismus begehen wir in Deutschland in
Ost und West den Frauentag ich finde das
ist eine gute Gelegenheit mal zu schauen
was wir erreicht haben fakt ist dass nur
35% der Mitglieder dieses Hauses Frauen
sind fakt ist das 40% aller Mädchen und
Frauen in Deutschland über 16
sexualisierte oder körperliche Gewalt
erlebt haben
Frauen immer noch durchschnittlich 18%
weniger als Männer verdienen Frauen mit
Migrationshintergrund sogar noch mal 20%
weniger als Herkunft deutsche Frauen ja
18 % Lohnunterschied zwischen Männern
und Frauen und ich weiß die ersten hier
verspüren den Drang zu rufen ja das ist
aber nur so weil die unterschiedliche
Jobs machen wenn das der gleiche ist ist
das ganz anders und Frauen entscheiden
sich nun mal für schlechter bezahlte
Jobs wirklich ist das deine angemessene
Reaktion wir können uns doch nicht
wirklich damit zufrieden geben dass
Frauenberufe eben schlechter bezahlt
sind und direkt in die Altersarmut
führen
Frau Ministerin Spiegel die sagen sie
nehmen den Kampf auf aber ich frage mich
wie denn es wird zwar an Feiertagen
darüber geredet aber seit Jahrzehnten
ändert sich kaum etwas eine Situation
und die strukturelle Ungleichheit
zwischen Männern und Frauen bleibt aber
warum ist das eigentlich so sorge
Pflegehaus und Erziehungsarbeit sind
Berufe ohne die eine Gesellschaft
niemals funktionieren kann und in den
traditionellen Frauen überrepräsentiert
sind weil es angeblich typische
Frauenberufe sind kümmern ist eben ein
weibliche Aufgabe sagen vor allem viele
Männer gern und am liebsten würde man
dieses kümmern diese Fürsorge ja sowieso
zerreiben Privatangelegenheit also von
Frauen natürlich erklären statt sie als
gesellschaftliche Aufgabe anzuerkennen
und dieses kümmern ist dann auch
angeblich keine Leistung sondern liegt
den Frauen halt im Blut und entsprechend
sieht es bei der Vergütung von Berufen
in diesem Bereichen dann aus der neuen
Bundesregierung ist es genauso bekannt
wie der alten vielleicht tun sie auch
mal was dagegen ich finde super wenn ich
mir den Koalitionsvertrag ansehe ist
meine Hoffnung da allerdings gering umso
wichtiger dass Verdi in den nächsten
Tagen in die tarifkämpfe im Bereich
sozial und erziehungsdienst ein
ich war viele Jahre in der Jugendhilfe
tätig soweit ich weiß gilt es für recht
wenige im Haus weniger aus dem sozialen
Bereich sind hier vertreten und daher
möchte ich diese einmalige Chance nutzen
meinen Kolleginnen für die
Tarifverhandlung viel Kraft und Erfolg
zu wünschen und Ihnen an dieser Stelle
für ihre Leistung zu danken
ob im Kindergarten im Jugendtreff in der
Schulsozialarbeit und überall wo ihr
euch kümmert leistet ihr unglaubliches
liebe Kolleginnen und dieses kümmern ist
keine einfache Arbeit wenn ihr vor
Erschöpfung kaum noch aufrecht stehen
könnt weil in der Kita Personalmangel
herrscht eure Überstunden sich stapeln
und ihr trotzdem gute Betreuung
geleistet wird wenn ihr in den frühesten
Morgenstunden bis tief in die Nacht für
die Menschen da seid weil ihr unbedingt
noch der Schülerin helfen wollt die
Angst hat am nächsten Tag in die Schule
zu gehen und wenn ihr keinen Schlaf
findet weil ihr den Gedanken nicht
verdrängen könntest eine der Familien
die er betreut vielleicht aus der
Wohnung geworfen wird und das sind keine
fiktiven Beispiele liebe Kolleginnen ihr
verdient mehr Geld und Anerkennung sowie
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen es braucht
endlich politische Maßnahmen gegen den
Fachkräftemangel
euer Kampf ist auch ein feministischer
Kampf ein Kampf um die Anerkennung und
Wertschätzung von sorgepflege und
Erziehungsarbeit das sind die zentralen
kampffelder und nicht irgendwelche
gender Debatten die sie immer wieder
aufziehen wollen
sondern stellvertreten für eine
solidarische gerechte und gleiche
Gesellschaft und ja wir führen diese
feministischen kämpfe seit Jahrzehnten
ich bin's auch leid ich hätte lieber
eine festrede gehalten aber dafür gibt
es noch viel zu viel zu tun trotzdem
schließe ich gern mit etwas Positivem
wenn das die Bedeutung des 8 März und
der damit verbundenen Kämpfe im
Rot-Rot-Grün regierten Berlin durch die
Einführung eines Feiertages gestärkt
wurde ist ein wichtiges Zeichen und auch
dass das Rot-Rot regierte
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern das gleiche plant
links wirkt vielen Dank
Heidi Reicheneck war das die Sprecherin
für Frauenpolitik der Linksfraktion hier
mit einer durchaus kritischen Rede aber
eben einem positiven Ausblick auch noch
und es schaust hat jetzt das Wort sie
Sprecherin für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend der Bündnis Grünen im
Deutschen Bundestag
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jedes Jahr
bietet der Internationale Frauentag uns
eine Chance nämlich die ehrlich auf die
Lage von Frauen zu schauen und daraus
politisches Handeln abzuleiten als Grüne
sind wir in der Koalition mit SPD und
FDP angetreten genau dies zu tun handeln
und dem Stillstand in puncto
Gleichstellung der viel zu lange
geherrscht hat ein Ende bereiten dass
der Aufruf der Ampelkoalition auch ein
feministischer ist haben sehr viel in
unserem Land
aufatmend begrüßt mit einer engagierten
Feministin als Frauenministerin eine
Außenministerin die aktiv
ein Zeichen mit feministischer
Außenpolitik setzt da wird klar auch das
empowerment von Frauen und
Menschenrechte stehen im Mittelpunkt und
das ist ein positives Zeichen für die
Frauen auch in unserem Land
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zur Wahrheit gehört auch dass die
corona-situation aktuell negativ auf die
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit wirkt die
strukturelle Ungerechtigkeit und
Ungleichheit führt laut einer neuen
Studie des WSI dazu das ist gerade die
Frauen sind die ihre Arbeitszeit
reduzieren und Homeschooling und
Kinderbetreuung auf sich nehmen Anfang
dieses Jahres hat jede fünfte Mutter
ihre Arbeitszeit wegen der pandemischen
Lage reduziert und das ist alarmierend
den Müttern geht massiv gehen massiv die
Kräfte aus und es geht nicht Frauen
weiter still und mit unentgeltlicher
Leistung auszulagern wir müssen Frauen
jetzt entlasten wir brauchen mehr als
nur kinderkrankentage die helfen alleine
nicht was hilft ist die Stärkung von
flexiblen Arbeitszeitmodellen etwa der
brückenteilzeit denn die ermöglicht
Frauen die Arbeit partnerschaftlicher
aufzuteilen und faire Aufteilung der
kehrarbeit die Abschaffung der
Steuerklassen 3 und 5 zwei Wochen Zeit
für den zweiten Elternteil nach der
Geburt die Weiterentwicklung des
Elterngeldes so verschaffen wir Frauen
wie der Perspektiven und die brauchen
Sie zügig
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen für den
größten Ungerechtigkeiten gehört nach
wie vor die Lohnlücke von 18 % für
Frauen und darum ist ein verbessertes
entgelttransparenzgesetz und das
verbandsklager Recht unerlässlich uns
ist ein Anliegen die Lage der Frauen mit
prekären Beschäftigungen die von
Ausbeutung und von Armut bedroht sind zu
verbessern da ist der Mindestlohn ein
wichtiger aber auch die Reform des AGG
ist unerlässlich denn gerade für Frauen
mit rassismuserfahrung oder mehrfach
Diskriminierung für Transfrauen Lesben
Frauen mit Behinderungen oder
Kopftuchträgerinnen ist das ein ganz
wichtiger Schritt
liebe Kolleginnen es ist für uns ein
Selbstverständnis dass wir für die
Rechte aller Frauen in ihrer ganzen
Vielfalt und würde einstehen nicht nur
am Frauentag sondern immer und
uneingeschränkt unser Feminismus ist
solidarisch und intersektional das gilt
beim gewaltschutz bei der Umsetzung der
istanbul-konvention genauso wieder wie
bei der Selbstbestimmung mir liegt
besonders am Herzen reproduktive Rechte
und körperliche Selbstbestimmung aller
Frauen und gebärfähigen Menschen zu
erreichen die Streichung des Paragraph
219a ist auf dem Weg das ist gut so wir
machen
Informationen über
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche für alle
Betroffenen zugänglich und schaffen
Rechtssicherheit für die Ärztinnen aber
auch die bereits verurteilten Ärztinnen
deren klagen beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht liegen wollen
wir eine Lösung bzw eine Form der
Entschädigung anbieten denn sie haben so
viel Druck ausgehalten und ich sage
ihnen gilt hier unser Dank
die Streichung des 219a ist
frauenpolitisch ein wichtiges Signal sie
löst aber nicht die prekäre
Versorgungslage beim
Schwangerschaftsabbruch in Deutschland
zu deren Absicherung wir im Bund und in
den Ländern verpflichtet sind liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und darum
müssen wir dringend das Verbessern es
gibt immer weniger Ärztinnen
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche müssen Teil der
ärztlichen Ausbildung werden als
Ampelkoalition werden wir in der
Kommission zur reproduktiven
Selbstbestimmung nach Lösungen suchen
dass ich an der Kriminalisierung
ungewollt Schwangere und Ärztinnen
endlich etwas ändern kann es ist
es ist wirklich Zeit eine
gesellschaftliche Debatte über
reproduktive Selbstbestimmung zu führen
und zwar sachlich faktenbasiert und
ergebnisoffen und die Forderungen aus
der UN frauenrechtskonvention zum
Schwangerschaftsabbruch in Deutschland
endlich umzusetzen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es gibt viel zu tun ich kann
sagen ich freue mich auf den
feministischen Aufbruch gemeinsam mit
allen engagierten Partnerinnen und eine
Regierung die frauenpolitisch den
Unterschied macht vielen Dank
ohne schaust war das für die Grünen
Fraktion hier im Deutschen Bundestag und
Ihnen wird es vielleicht aufgefallen
sein bisher haben wir nur Frauen
gesprochen in dieser Debatte zum
Internationalen Frauentag und auch die
nächste Rednerin ist eine Frau Mechthild
heil
in Wissenschaft in Forschung und den
technischen Berufen freundlich
formuliert es könnte wirklich viel viel
besser sein der Internationale Frauentag
und manch andere Initiative wie den
Girls Day Initiative klischeefrei oder
you could Girls die sind
Vorzeigeprojekte und uns allen bekannt
aber
anscheinend entfalten sie nicht die
erhoffte Wirkung wieder in den
Kindergärten in der Kita noch in der
Schule auch nicht bei der Wahl des
Ausbildungsberufes oder des Studienfachs
die sind Befund muss man so fassen und
er muss uns in Alarmbereitschaft
versetzen denn unsere Arbeitswelt hier
mitten in Deutschland ist im Wandel und
eine solide mint-bildung ist aber die
Grundlage für unseren Reichtum in
unserem Land für unseren Wirtschaft und
unseren Wissenschaftsstandort
Deutschland
und wir haben kluge Köpfe in unserem
Land beim Abitur liegen die Frauen schon
weit vor den Männern junge Frauen sind
heute so gut ausgebildet wie sie noch
nie in unserer Geschichte waren das ist
eine wirkliche frauenpolitische
Erfolgsgeschichte aber die Frage die
Frage bleibt doch warum ergreifen dann
nur wenige Frauen auch technisch
naturwissenschaftliche Berufe was
hindert eigentlich uns Frauen da rein
was schenkt uns ein was sind die
Vorurteile in der in unserer
Gesellschaft wer muss an der Stelle was
tun
der richtige Blickwinkel ist
entscheidend die Frage muss lauten
wir müssen Ausbildungs- und
Arbeitsbedingungen verändert werden
damit Frauen zukunftsweisende technisch
orientierte Berufe ergreifen und dann
auch in diesem Berufen Karriere machen
können ich will den drei Aspekte nennen
fangen wir in der Kita und in der Schule
an natürlich werden da die Grundsteine
gelegt immens Bereich wie in jedem
anderen Bereich auch also Mädchen und
Frauen können natürlich Mathematik sie
können Informatik sie können Natur und
Ingenieurwissenschaften oder Technik
Schule und die Umwelt die können diese
Fähigkeiten stärken oder eben auch
verkümmern lassen
Bundesministerin Anja Karliczek unsere
ehemalige Bundesministerin hat dafür ein
Programm eingeführt Mission Mint ich bin
gespannt was die Ampel daraus macht ob
sie es weiterführt der nächste Blick ist
auf die Hochschule könnten wir auch
sagen in die Politik wir brauchen davor
Bilder wir brauchen weibliche Vorbilder
und eine gezielte Förderung von Frauen
in der Wissenschaft deshalb haben sich
die Bund und haben sich bunt und Ländern
auch auf ein Programm geeinigt
Professorin Programm heißt es ist Geld
ist bis 2022 da ich bin gespannt ob auch
die Finanzierung über das Datum hinaus
hier von der Regierung gemacht wird und
ganz wichtig was immer in der Debatte
vergessen dass der dritte Punkt wir
müssen doch hinschauen was machen denn
Industrie und Gewerbe wir betrachten wir
brauchen auch als Frauen ein
betriebsumfeld dass wir uns Frauen
genauso passt wie es für die Männer über
Jahrzehnte und Jahrhunderte passend
gemacht wurde das gilt für die
Gestaltung von Werkzeugen von
Materialien die wir und Maschinen die
wir haben das gilt für die Größe für die
Gewichte ganz furchtbar viele Dinge und
das gilt natürlich auch für die
Vorstände und auch die Aufsichtsräte
wenn Sie die aktuelle Diskussion eines
großen Konzerns hören der sagt wir
können uns eine Frau im Vorstand
vorstellen aber nur zum Einkauf aber in
der Entwicklung von Motoren können wir
uns das nicht vorstellen dann ist das
ein Armutszeugnis unserer Gesellschaft
und dieser Vorstände
und einige von ihnen wissen ich bin
selber Architektin ich bin selber
Ingenieurin als ich in diesem Beruf
gefunden habe als ich da rein finden
wollte war so gut wie unmöglich im
Bereich bauen eine Praktikumsstelle zu
bekommen und geschweige denn in der
ganzen Baubranche überhaupt einen
Ausbildungsplatz zu bekommen es hat sich
zum Glück viel geändert seitdem
aber manches ist noch genauso suchen Sie
einen Bauleiter an der Baustelle finden
Sie ihn sofort aber eine Bauleiterin
ganz selten von einer gleichberechtigten
Teilhabe ist deswegen noch lange nicht
die rede dir als cduceu-fraktion setzen
uns weiter für eine wirklich
gleichberechtigte Teilhabe ein
Dankeschön
[Applaus]
so und jetzt haben wir den einzigen Mann
der in dieser Debatte sprechen wird dass
es Erik von Malotki aus der SPD-Fraktion
und es ist seine erste Rede im Deutschen
Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Ministerin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ist für mich eine große Ehre dass ich
heute anlässlich des Internationalen
Frauentages meine erste Rede im
Deutschen Bundestag halten darf ich
möchte diese Gelegenheit nutzen um ihn
von drei Frauen zu berichten deren
Engagement mich nachhaltig beeindruckt
hat ich bin davon überzeugt dass wir
eine Menge von diesen Frauen lernen
können
ich möchte ihn von Marlies Heinze einer
ehemaligen gebäudereinigerin aus
Pasewalk berichten Marlies engagiert
sich in ihrer Nachbarschaft für ein
Familie die von Abschiebung bedroht ist
ich habe Marlies bei einer Demonstration
für faire Löhne für Reinigungskräfte in
Greifswald kennengelernt mit 72 Jahren
setzt sich Marlies immer noch in ihre
Gewerkschaft für andere ein sie kämpft
für bessere Arbeitsbedingungen für
ehemaligen Kollegen von denen immer noch
viel zu viele im Niedriglohnsektor
feststecken
lassen Sie uns für Marlies und für
Millionen andere Frauen dafür sorgen
dass jahrelanges ehrenamtliches
Engagement mit einer höheren Rente
belohnt wird
kann nicht sein dass sich Frauen gegen
einen Ehrenamt entscheiden weil sie
Angst vor Altersarmut haben es kann
nicht sein dass Frauen das größte Risiko
für Altersarmut haben das ist eine
schreiende Ungerechtigkeit die wir
beenden werden
ich möchte Ihnen von Peggy Lehm erzählen
sie ist Wirtschaftsjuristin und Mutter
eines tollen Schwerbehinderten Sohnes
Peggy setzt sich mit einer unglaublichen
Entschlossenheit und für bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen und kleinere Gruppen
in die Kitas in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
ein hierfür hat sie mit anderen
engagierten über 14.000 Unterschriften
für erfolgreiche Bürgerbegehren in der
Region Rostock gesammelt als Ergebnis
werden mehr als 100 Stellen für
Erzieherin neu geschaffen
für Frauen die Peggy müssen wir die
Bedingungen in den Kitas deutlich
verbessern wir werden das Gute
Kita-Gesetz weiterentwickeln und ein
bundesqualitätsgesetz schaffen das heißt
konkret mehr Erzieherin und eine bessere
bessere frühkindliche Bildung für unsere
Kleinsten
und da ist Luisa Kunert Erzieherin und
alleinerziehende Mutter einer kleinen
Tochter Luisa setzt sich mit Herz Blut
und gegen alle Widerstände für ein
fairen Lohn und mehr Mitbestimmung in
ihrer Kita ein heute ist die Vorsitz des
Betriebsrats und ihre Kollegin haben
einen Tarifvertrag
sie hat dafür gekämpft dass mehr als 160
Erzieherin aus dem niedrigen und Sektor
rauskommen und sie hat gewonnen
Frauen die Luisa müssen wir bei ihrem
Einsatz für gute Löhne und Mitbestimmung
noch mehr unterstützen wir werden die
Rahmenbedingungen für Tarifverträge
verbessern und so die Tarifbindung
erhöhen wer keinen Tariflohn zahlt
braucht nicht auf öffentliche Aufträge
zu hoffen
wir werden uns darum kümmern dass
niemand bei der Gründung eines
Betriebsrats ausgebremst wird wer
demokratische Mitbestimmung im Betrieb
verhindert bekommt Post von der
Staatsanwaltschaft
[Applaus]
Marlies Peggy und Luisa
it die Entschlossenheit sich für ihre
Mitmenschen einzusetzen auch ohne
Aussicht auf Anerkennung sie hätten es
verdient hier an meiner Stelle im
Deutschen Bundestag zu stehen
lassen sie mich zum Abschluss noch ein
persönlich Versprechen abgeben der zu
geringe Anteil von Frauen auf allen
Ebenen der Politik ist ein Skandal umso
besser ist es das hier im Bundestag in
fast allen Fraktionen
es engagierte Kollegin gibt die mit so
viel Power die Spielregeln der Politik
verändern sie arbeiten daran dass
zukünftig keine Gläsern entdecken und
keine Männerbünde mehr verhindern dass
Frauen ihre Träume verwirklichen sie und
ihr könnt euch sicher sein dass sie euch
bei diesem Kampf unterstützen werde
danke
Erik von Malotki hat hier seine
Unterstützung angekündigt in seiner
ersten Rede hier im Deutschen Bundestag
nächste Rednerin in der Debatte zum
Internationalen Frauentag der zum
101sten ersten Mal gefeiert wird ist
Beatrix von Storch afd-fraktion
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzender
Frauen werden abgeschafft das ist der
Titel eines Beitrags in der Emma von der
Harry Potter Harry Potter Erfinderin j.k
rowling und sie fast alle hier betreiben
genau das sie fast alle hier sind Frauen
abschaffer weil sie fast alle hier der
Gender Ideologie anhängen sie behaupten
das Geschlecht hat mit Biologie nichts
zu tun und jeder kann sich sein
Geschlecht irgendwie selbst bestimmen da
selbstbestimmungsgesetz kommt dann hier
demnächst auch in diesem Theater wir
warten schon mit Freude drauf rolling
hat es
Ideologie gefährdet vor allem Frauen und
Mädchen Männer brechen Rekorde im
Frauenschwimmen Männer in der Damen
Umkleide Sexualverbrecher im
Frauengefängnis weil sie sich gerade als
Frauen für lowling lehnt diesen Quatsch
ab und wird deswegen mit obsessiven Hass
verfolgt die transideologie ist
totalitär und sie ist zwangsläufig
totalitär wer so offenkundig die Natur
die Wahrheit leugnet der muss die
Wahrheit selbst zum Verbrechen erklären
und jeden der die Wahrheit ausspricht
zum Verbrecher
der Bundestag liefert ein gutes Beispiel
wenn der Kollege Markus ganserer Rock
Lippenstift hackenschuhe trägt dann ist
das völlig in Ordnung es ist aber seine
Privatsache biologisch und juristisch
ist und bleibt er ein Mann und wenn er
als solcher über die grüne Frauenquote
in den Bundestag einzieht und hier als
Frau geführt wird ist das schlicht
rechtswidrig ich bin Markus ganserer
aber für zwei Dinge dankbar erstens weil
sein Beispiel und so schön vor Augen
führt dass es einen Unterschied macht ob
man sich als Frau verkleidet oder ob man
eine Frau ist und weil er zweitens die
Frauenquote final hat absurdum geführt
hat hätte sich Robert Habeck im
richtigen Moment als Roberta bezeichnet
dann wäre Roberta vermutlich jetzt
Bundeskanzlerin
der querbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
Sven Lehmann meint jeder der Herr
ganzerer nicht als Frau akzeptiert sei
transform transform ist offensichtlich
ein anderes Wort für nicht blöd und
nicht blöd sind auch die Nationen von
Geschlecht zählt das sind ausdrücklich
Feministinnen und Grüne die gegen ganzer
assmandat nun klagen sie verstehen dass
es ohne Biologie keine Frauen gibt und
ohne Frauen auch keine Frauenrechte am
Weltfrauentag ist ein guter Moment um
festzustellen ein Fisch ist kein Fahrrad
ein Mann ist keine Frau und gender ist
Gaga jeder Wahrheit braucht einen
Mutigen der sie ausspricht und in diesem
Parlament ist das die AFD vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Frau von Storch sie haben vorhin hier
dieses Parlament als Theater bezeichnet
ich bitte Sie sehr über diesen Begriff
noch einmal nachzudenken sie sind ja
selbst Abgeordnete des Deutschen
Bundestages und in ansonsten bitte ich
sie einfach auch persönlich um Respekt
vor der Kollegin Tessa ganderer jetzt
gebe ich
das Wort
zu einer Kurzintervention der Kollegin
Britta Hasselmann
frau Präsidentin
das was die Abgeordnete Storch sich
gerade in diesem Haus erlaubt hat ist
niederträchtig
niederträchtig bodenlos es ist homophob
und zutiefst menschenverachtend
aber dieses Haus ist ein Haus der
Demokratie und der freien Rede und
deshalb konnte sie das hier sagen es
erschüttert mich zu tiefst dass jemand
über eine Kollegin im Deutschen
Bundestag so abscheulich und
niederträchtig spricht meine Damen und
Herren und das ist erschüttern
und ich wende mich wirklich an sie alle
tessa gansera ist eine von uns sie ist
meine und unsere Kollegin sie ist eine
der 59% Anteil Frauen in dieser Fraktion
und niemand von uns hat darüber zu
richten
oder darüber zu reden oder zu
entscheiden wie diese Frau ihr
Selbstbestimmungsrecht wahrnimmt
und ich bin ihm ich bin Ihnen
sehr dankbar dass sie durch ihren
Applaus der Öffentlichkeit zeigen dass
sie diese Haltung teilen und das ist ein
gutes Gefühl und eine Unterstützung für
meine Kollegin Tessa ganzer ich danke
Ihnen von Herzen dafür wir sollten
zusammenstehen bei aller
Unterschiedlichkeit in der Sache als
demokratische Kräfte wenn eine solche
Menschenverachtung hier im Haus passiert
stellen wir uns dem entgegen danke dafür
Britta Hasselmann von der grünen
Fraktion war das mit einer
Kurzintervention
Beatrix von Storch kann nun darauf
antworten wenn sie möchte
[Applaus]
keine Kurzintervention angemeldet
möchten Sie das tun
ich bin gerade in einer Weise persönlich
angegriffen worden dass ich dazu gerne
Stellung nehmen möchte
möchten Sie eine Kurzintervention
dann gebe ich Ihnen das
alles gut vielen Dank ich gebe Ihnen
jetzt noch einmal das Wort zu einer
Kurzintervention das eröffnet aber
natürlich die Möglichkeit dass darauf
auch wieder geantwortet werden kann und
dann ist der dieser
[Musik]
so ich gebe Ihnen jetzt das Wort die
sind persönlich angesprochen worden und
dann werde ich hier diesen Sitzung
weiterleiten in der Hoffnung dass das
möglich ist und wenn Sie Frau von Storch
jetzt die Ruhe geben dass sie auch
sprechen kann und nicht mehr weiter
dazwischen rufen dann kann das auch
beginnen Frau von
ich finde das eine außerordentlich
interessante Debatte und sie zeigt wohin
es führt ich habe ausdrücklich gesagt
jeder kann privat machen was er möchte
aber es gibt bestimmte Voraussetzungen
unter denen man juristisch sein
Geschlecht wechseln kann
Markus gansera ist als solches auch im
Bayerischen Landtag geführt worden hat
sich ausdrücklich dagegen entschieden
die juristischen Wege zu gehen die es
benötigt um sein Geschlecht zu wechseln
und auf dieser Seite ist der juristisch
weiterhin ein Mann und er ist biologisch
ein Mann und wir wissen dass das
selbstbestimmungsgesetz kommt dass jeder
hier in diesem Land sein Geschlecht
persprechakt ändern kann
das halten wir für absurd und es ist
eben auch absurd wenn man dann als
selbsterklärter Mann eine Frauenquote in
Anspruch nehmen kann und deswegen sind
es Feministinnen und Grüne die genau
dagegen klagen weil es eben gegen die
Frauenrechte ist wenn jemand der sich
selbst als Mann erklärt als als Frau
erklärte ein Mann ist diese Quote in
Anspruch nehmen kann das ist nicht die
AFD das sind grüne und Feministen die
dagegen klagen weil sie das eben genau
nicht wollen das Geschlecht ist eine
biologische Tatsache dass sie jetzt noch
juristisch aufladen wollen weil sie es
trennen wollen aber nicht mal diesen Weg
ist Markus gansera bisher gegangen und
deswegen sage ich noch einmal was jemand
in seiner Privatheit macht das steht ihm
völlig frei darüber ist nicht zu
urteilen dass es eine Entscheidung wie
man sein Leben führen möchte aber es
kann die Gesellschaft nicht gezwungen
werden jemand der juristisch ein Mann
ist und der biologisch ein Mann ist
einfach als Frau annehmen zu müssen und
auch für ihn die qu
so nachdem sie jetzt noch einmal
Gelegenheit hatten auf die
persönlichen
Anwürfe zu reagieren geht die Debatte
jetzt weiter und ich freue mich dass die
Kollegin Tessa ganzera im Haus ist und
gebe aber jetzt das Wort der Kolleginnen
Dieter Jensen für die FDP-Fraktion
sexuelle Identität nicht verstanden und
ich glaube das ist das Problem
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen online ersting ist for a little
respect
1967 hat Aretha Franklin in einer
feministischen Hymne einfach ein
bisschen mehr Respekt eingefordert knapp
50 Jahre später schrieb Beyoncé
vermutlich die feministische Hymne für
das 21 Jahrhundert world
wir wollen nicht einfach nur Respekt wir
wollen auch nicht einfach nur am Tisch
setzen wir wollen die Welt regieren und
ja ich weiß wenn Frauen solche Ansprüche
hier stellen woanders Stellen macht das
im Jahr 2022 noch vielen Menschen Angst
bei manchen löst diese Anspruchshaltung
gar unbändigen Hass aus und deshalb bin
ich sehr froh dass wir mit dieser neuen
Bundesregierung und mit dieser neuen
Koalition ihnen allen zeigen können dass
es dafür nicht den geringsten Grund gibt
bei unseren Vorhaben im Bereich
Gleichstellung und das kann jeder in
unserem Koalitionsvertrag ja nachlesen
geht es darum geht es nicht darum dass
Feministinnen die Welt unter Jochen
wollen es geht darum dass jede Frau das
jedes Mädchen an ihr Leben in dieser
Welt die gleichen Ansprüche stellen darf
wie jeder Mann und jeder Junge dass sie
die gleichen Träume träumen darf und
dass sie dann auch noch die gleichen
Chancen hat genau diese Träume
Wirklichkeit werden zu lassen es
bedeutet auch dass wir einer Bürgerin
die gleiche Mündigkeit zusprechen wie
einen Bürger dieses Landes die
Fähigkeiten ihr Leben selbstbestimmt und
eigenverantwortlich zu leben ich weiß
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union sie versuchen mit aller Kraft auch
hier immer wieder in der Debatte
umzudeuten was wir mit der Abschaffung
von Paragraph
219a erreichen möchten und deswegen
erkläre ich das noch mal kurz worum es
eigentlich da vor allen Dingen für die
Frauen geht und warum sie es als
Befreiungsschlag empfinden werden es
geht darum dass wir im Jahr 22 Frauen
zutrauen fachliche Informationen von
Ärztinnen und Ärzten zu verstehen und
einzuordnen und es geht darum dass wir
im Jahr 2022 Frauen zutrauen eine der
schwersten Entscheidungen überhaupt
eigenverantwortlich und mit allen
Konsequenzen zu treffen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
wollen einen level playing fiel dafür
bin ich angetreten dafür sind wir
angetreten wir wollen keinen
startvorsprung wir wollen die gleichen
Schuhe und wir wollen den gleichen
Trainingsplan und dazu gehört es dass
wir etwas ändern wenn gesellschaftliche
Klischees wenn Normen Frauen ihres
Potentials berauben es kann nicht sein
dass Mädchen denken Mädchen können kein
Mathe und deswegen bin ich froh dass wir
eine Bundesbildungsministerin jetzt
haben die sich damit nicht abfinden wird
wenn wir wir in den vergangenen zwei
Jahren Pandemie merken dass die
Rahmenbedingungen zur Vereinbarkeit von
Familie und Beruf die wir derzeit haben
die funktionieren offenbar nur unter
Optimalbedingungen manchmal unter
Normalbedingungen aber auf gar keinen
Fall unter Ausnahmebedingungen da
brechen sie regelmäßig ineinander
zusammen und deswegen werden wir das
anpacken
Gleichberechtigung werden wir dann
erreichen wenn ich hier nicht mehr vom
Bier spreche und alle wissen wer gemeint
ist wir werden Sie dann erreichen wenn
bei Frauen als Individuen wahrnehmen und
nicht mehr als Stellvertreterin ihres
Geschlechts wenn unsere Außenministerin
Annalena baerbock nicht mehr die Frau
ist die ist mit autokratisch
herrschenden Männern in der Welt
aufnehmen kann wenn unsere Ministerin
Nancy fazer nicht mehr die Frau ist die
ein hartes Ressort besetzt wenn eines
Tages nicht mehr Frauen als
Stellvertreterinnen ihres Geschlechts
die Welt regieren sondern Angela Merkel
Justin da Adam to Reza may sanamarin und
viele mehr genau dann ist für uns als
Liberale das Versprechen auf
Gleichberechtigung auch erfüllt
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank soweit geht die ganzen
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der
FDP-Fraktion und nächste Rednerin ist
Yvonne markwas sie ist viel zu
Präsidentin des Deutschen Bundestags
aber natürlich auch cdu/csu Mitglied und
auch gerade beim Phoenix Podcast unter
drei zu Gast gewesen mit Erhard Schäfer
und Thorsten Fass
4458 das ist meine schreckenzahl der
Woche
4458 zu viel Fälle von Angriffen
Beleidigungen und Bedrohungen gegen
Politiker und eben PolitikerInnen
diese Zahl hat das Bundeskriminalamt
2021 gezählt
die Gewalt gegen Frauen ist ein großes
und es ist ein wachsendes Problem in der
analogen und insbesondere auch in der
digitalen Welt vor allem politisch
argumentierende politisch aktive Frauen
sind Ziel von herabwürdigungen betrogen
bis hin zu Mord aufrufen
Frauen erleben zudem diese Angriffe
stärker als Männer in sexualisierter
Form laut einer aktuellen Studie der
Europäischen Akademie für Frauen in
Politik und Wirtschaft gemeinsam mit
Allensbach haben 77% der Politikerinnen
auf Landesebene und
98% der Politikerinnen auf Bundesebene
diese Erfahrung vor allem in Bezug auf
die sozialen Netzwerke bereits gemacht
wahrscheinlich können wir alle hier ein
trauriges Lied davon singen
in der virtuellen Welt auch immer
häufiger Untaten im wirklichen Leben
Folgen zeigen leider auch die Zahlen des
Bundeskriminalamtes die Straftaten gegen
amts- und Mandatsträger haben sich in
den vergangenen vier Jahren fast
verdreifacht grund dafür sind auch die
durch Corona bedingte Radikalisierung in
den sozialen Netzwerken zum Beispiel auf
Telegramm
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich sehe
die große Gefahr dass sich Frauen aus
dem Netz zurückziehen oder ihre
politischen Ambitionen auffallen lassen
und gerade auf kommunaler Ebene wo wir
nur 9,5% Landrätinnen und 10%
BürgermeisterInnen in Deutschland haben
ist das ein fatales Signal
und ich sehe ein groß daraus ein großes
gesellschaftliches Problem auf uns
zukommen denn es ist auch eine ja eine
Einschlag gegen die Demokratie und die
Demokratie steht damit auch auf dem
Spiel und dagegen müssen wir aus meiner
Sicht etwas tun und zwar mehr als bisher
wir brauchen wirklich die aktive
Bündelung aller Kräfte aus Gesellschaft
aus Politik aus Justiz und von den
Plattform betreiben
es ist gut dass wir Innenminister von
Bund und Länder im vorigen Jahr zwei
wichtige Beschlüsse gefasst haben zum
einen eine frauenspezifische
Kriminalstatistik auf dem Weg zu bringen
und zum anderen aber auch konsequenter
gegen Straftaten zum Nachteil von Amts
und mandatstrike und vorzugehen das ist
wichtig denn es braucht neben klare
Haltung auch ein konsequentes Vorgehen
und mit dem
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz und mit dem
Gesetz zur Bekämpfung des
Rechtsextremismus und der
Hasskriminalität hat die Union in den
letzten zwei Legislaturperioden wichtige
Instrumente zur Bekämpfung von Hetze und
der Strafbarkeit von Tätern im Netz
beschlossen Deutschland hat damit eine
Vorreiterrolle eingenommen in Europa und
mit neuen Hass verbreitenden Plattformen
wie telegram oder schlimmeren Exzessen
müssen die Gesetze gegebenenfalls auch
noch geschärft werden
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Ampel hier dürfen wir eben nicht
rückwärts gehen
da reichen eben keine schönen Reden und
Bekenntnisse zu Wehr
haften dich gerade immer so lesen nein
da brauchen wir konkrete und
wirkungsvolle Instrumente ein Recht auf
völlige Anonymität im Internet und auch
die Ankündigung von Bundesjustizminister
Buschmann die Vorratsdatenspeicherung
abzuschaffen ohne Lösungsvorschläge zu
bringen stehen im krassen Widerspruch zu
den Erfordernissen der
kriminalkriminalitätsbekämpfung im
digitalen Raum die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden benötigen eben
gerade ein Meer und nicht ein weniger an
ermittlungsbefugnissen und natürlich
auch mehr Personal in dieser Frage zu
oft wird der Datenschutz ins Feld
geführt um den Behörden größeren
Handlungsspielraum zu verwehren
Opferschutz meine Damen und Herren muss
im Vordergrund stehen
und die Plattformen müssen nach wie vor
stärker ihre Verantwortung für das
gerecht werden was auf ihren Seiten auch
gepostet wird und in Anbetracht der
rasant steigenden Zahlen des PKA bin ich
auch dafür dass wir ernsthaft noch uns
mal auf das Thema Klarnamen Pflicht im
Internet verständigen dazu vielleicht
auch noch mal diskutieren die Anonymität
erhöht immer die Hemmschwelle auch
hasskommentare abzuschicken lassen Sie
uns diesen Weg bestreiten abschließend
meine Damen und Herren ein Zitat von
Rita Süßmuth Feministin zu sein ist das
mindeste was man als Frau tun kann von
mir auch ein herzlichen Glückwunsch an
dieser Stelle an Rita Süßmuth wir haben
ja viel zu verdanken herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Mark was war deswegen
religionsfraktion und während der Rede
haben wir hier auch immer wieder aus den
Reihen der Grünen gesehen Kolleginnen
die zu Tessa gansera gegangen werden die
Abgeordnete die hier sehr stark
angegriffen wurde
in die Debatte
nun kommen wir zu Sarah larkamp
SPD-Fraktion Kinderbeauftragte und
Neuling im Bundestag hier mit ihrer
ersten Rede
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen weltweit werden
zum Weltfrauentag am 8 März schöne Regen
gehalten diesen müssen auch Taten folgen
einiges haben wir in Deutschland schon
erreicht aber es gibt auch noch viel zu
tun daran erinnert der Weltfrauentag
es geht um faire Chancen es geht um
Gerechtigkeit und es geht um Respekt
für Mütter z.B als Mutter von vier
Kindern weiß ich was viele Frauen jeden
Tag leisten morgens früh aufstehen die
Kinder fertig machen zur Schule bringen
zur Arbeit hätten zum Einkaufen bei den
Hausaufgaben helfen die Wäsche machen
und und und
am Ende des Tages bleibt kaum mehr Zeit
für sich selbst und ich ich klage noch
auf vom Niveau denn ich habe einen
wirklich tollen Mann der sich um die
Kinder kümmert während ich hier zu Ihnen
sprechen darf
doch das ist im Jahre 2022 in
Deutschland häufig immer noch die
Ausnahme von der Regel
veraltete Rollenbilder und Strukturen
stehen Frauen im Weg im ländlichen Raum
häufig noch mehr als in der Großstadt
und sie ignorieren auch die
Vielfältigkeit moderner
Familienkonstellation z.B tragen
Alleinerziehende allein die
Verantwortung für ihre Familie und
arbeiten quasi nebenbei in der Regel
betrifft das Frauen
Respekt Gerechtigkeit und faire Chancen
verlangen auch dass wir etwas dagegen
unternehmen dass Frauen durchschnittlich
18% weniger hier Stunde verdienen als
Männer sie arbeiten häufig in schlecht
bezahlter berufen und verdienen selbst
dort noch weniger als ihre männlichen
Kollegen ich bin froh dass die
Bundesregierung diese Frauen mit einem
deutlich höheren Mindestlohn von 12 €
pro Stunde stärken will
Frauen profitieren am meisten davon
aber mit dem höheren Mindestlohn wäre
noch nicht für die Frauen getan die
kehrarbeit in der eigenen Familie
unentgeltlich leisten Frauen wenden pro
Tag im Schnitt 52,4% mehr Zeit für
unbezahlte sorgearbeit auf als Männer
deshalb arbeiten sie häufiger ein
Teilzeit zahlen weniger in die eigene
Altersvorsorge ein und sind am Ende
stärker von Altersarmut bedroht es darf
nicht sein das sorgearbeit also der
Dienst an Familie und Gesellschaft zu
Abend im Alter führt
Frauen brauchen flexiblere Strukturen um
am Wirtschaftsleben teilzuhaben mit der
brückenteilzeit haben wir 2019 ein
wichtiges Instrument eingeführt Frauen
die Kinder erziehen Angehörige pflegen
oder sich ehrenamtlich engagieren wollen
haben größere Spielräume bekommen die
Möglichkeit zu brückenteilzeit besteht
übrigens auch für Männer vielleicht ist
das auch ein weiterer Anreiz damit sie
mehr kehraufgaben übernehmen manche tun
das schließlich richtig gerne
gute Frauenpolitik dient also auch
Männer und hilft ihnen aus
unfreiwilligen Rollen auszubrechen gute
Frauenpolitik ist gute Familienpolitik
die die Vielfältigkeit von
Familienformen in unserem Land stärkt
und es Frauen wie Männern ermöglicht
flexibel aus veränderte Lebensumstände
zu reagieren daran werden wir weiter
arbeiten damit Frauen Mütter und
Familien so leben können wie sie es
möchten und die Unterstützung bekommen
die sie brauchen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
als nächstes erhält das Wort die
Kollegin Dorothee Bär
geehrter Herr Präsident meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen freue mich sehr
dass wir heute zum Weltfrauentag
sprechen der sich zum 111 mal lehrt der
erste
Weltfrauentag war am 19 märz 1911 und
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen Frau harder
köhnel Frau von Storch wenn man sich
ihre Reden angehört hat hatte man das
Gefühl mal wer im Jahr 1912 gelandet
19.11 gelandet es war wirklich
unterirdisch was ich hier heute von sich
gegeben haben wobei ich auch das Gefühl
hatte Frau 1911 wann aufgeklärter als
die gesamte afd-fraktion bis heute 20
gegeben hat
überlegt dass sie hier mal
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin haben werden
wollen kann ich nur für mich persönlich
sagen niemals so gerne jemanden nicht
gewählt haben das war wirklich peinlich
was sie relativ leicht gemacht
aber jetzt auch mal zum Thema und zum
Thema Frauen und auch von dieser Stelle
aus wirklich noch mal ein ganz klares
ein ganz deutliches Bekenntnis auch aus
der Opposition raus in dieser
Legislaturperiode wie wichtig und das
Thema Frauen insgesamt ist wichtig uns
die Themen Gleichberechtigung kehrarbeit
komme ich gleich dazu sehen das sieht
man auch daran dass von allen möglichen
Fraktionsvorsitzenden in diesem Hohen
Haus nur der unsere da ist Liebe
Friedrich Merz vielen herzlichen Dank
sie müssen gar nicht schreiben ich habe
gesagt von den möglichen
Fraktionsvorsitzenden so und die anderen
sind leider nicht daher du Herr Mütze
nicht das hätte vielleicht auch nicht
geschadet an der Stelle wir nehmen das
Thema wirklich sehr ernst und deswegen
freue ich mich dass wir die Möglichkeit
haben auch noch mal darüber zu sprechen
nicht nur wo wir stehen nicht nur zu
lamentieren nicht nur vielleicht an der
ein oder anderen Stelle dies der Kollege
von der SPD gemacht hat zu sagen welche
Frauen er uns vorstellen willst sondern
ich hätte mir schon erwartet dass von
den ampelparteien auch von den
Fraktionen mal konkrete Vorschläge
kommen was in den nächsten vier Jahren
geplant ist das wäre gut gewesen und wir
hatten natürlich irgendwie das Gefühl
dass sie hier nicht zum Weltfrauentag
sprechen sondern glauben heute ist der
internationale Welt Vorlesetag nur ein
paar schöne Geschichten reichen nicht
und reichen Frauen in unserem Land mit
hat gesagt wir Frauen wollen die Welt
regieren das machen wir als Union das
machen wir als EVP wenn ich mir mit
Kristin Lagat Ursula von der Leyen und
Roberta mit sola anschaut dass wir drei
Frauen an der Spitze der europäischen
Institutionen haben ist es sicherlich
auch etwas was es wert ist an dem Tag
auch behandelt zu werden aber vielleicht
noch mal zwei drei Probleme die sich in
den vergangenen zwei Jahren verschärft
haben die noch mal ersichtlicher wurden
wenn jetzt mitten immer noch in einer
Pandemie stehen die sich hoffentlich dem
Ende Zune halten müssen wir eben
konstatieren dass wir diese Pandemie
nicht nur aus Gesundheitlichen sondern
aus wirtschaftlichen
Veränderungsprozessen betrachten sondern
eben ganz besonders noch mal die
Gesellschaftspolitik in den Blick nehmen
und da bleibt eben festzuhalten dass uns
da die Aufgaben nicht ausgehen werden
und ich auch persönlich mit dem Status
Quo nicht zufrieden bin
viele Frauen das ist angesprochen worden
sind in sogenannten systemrelevanten
Bereichen tätig nicht nur Erziehung und
Pflege was angesprochen wurde sondern
eben auch z.B in der Gastronomie in der
Hotellerie im Gewerbe und da waren eben
ganz besonders Frauen von der Pandemie
betroffen und es hatte zur Folge dass
die Aufteilung zwischen erwerbs- und
sorgearbeit auch in den Haushalten immer
wieder neu verhandelt werden musste und
damit natürlich auch bei den
Verhandlungen ist immer sehr stark darum
geht wie schaut's aus mit langfristigen
Karrierechancen und meistens ging das
Ganze eben zu lassen der Frauen und uns
ist als Fraktion ein Thema ganz
besonders wichtig nicht erst neu sondern
das haben wir auch in der letzten
Legislatur schon immer wieder auf die
tagungs Tagesordnung gebracht das ist
die Betroffenheit und die Widrigkeiten
für unsere Alleinerziehende in diesem
Land wir haben über 2,6 Millionen Väter
aber ganz besonders Mütter die
alleinerziehend sind die hier nicht die
Möglichkeit haben sich erwerbs- und
sorgearbeit aufzuteilen in
sie tragen die doppelte Verantwortung
sie tragen die doppelten sorgen viele
Arbeiten in Teilzeit machen dafür
Abstriche bei ihrem Verdienst bei ihren
Karrierechancen aber auch fast die
Hälfte arbeitet in Vollzeit und für die
wollen wir in dieser Legislatur noch
mehr erreichen als wir schon in den
letzten Jahren getan haben
wir wollen Ihnen nicht nur den Rücken
stärken wir wollen Ihnen nicht nur eben
durch wohlfeile Worte sagen dass sie
eine tolle Arbeit leisten sondern wir
haben in der letzten Legislaturperiode
durchgesetzt dass wir den
Steuerfreibetrag auf 4000 € erhöht haben
wir schlagen vor ihm jetzt auf 5000 € zu
erhöhen wir brauchen aber noch mehr
Maßnahmen wir wollen eine Erhöhung des
Wohngeldes oder ein Sofortbonus für
Kinder um den möglichst schnelle
Verbesserung auch zu erreichen und sehr
geehrte Ministerin Spiegel sie haben ja
auch immer von sofort sofort gesprochen
sofort es auch so ein blumiges Wort
sofort es eigentlich jetzt und ich würde
mich freuen wenn sie schon erst im April
in den Ausschuss kommen dass sie
vielleicht mit der Politik trotzdem ein
bisschen früher anfangen als es bislang
der Fall war
und weil sich ja um die Familienpolitik
in dem Land zumindest wenn man es jeden
Tag in der Zeitung liest mehr Herr
Buschmann kümmert würde ich mich einfach
freuen wenn Sie sich vielleicht in der
Frauenpolitik etwas mehr engagieren ein
Beispiel auch an der Kollegin baerbock
nehmen die hat jetzt in Spanien eine
sonderstaatsanwaltschaft für Gewalt
gegen Frauen besucht das könnte doch
auch ein Beispiel sein was für uns für
Deutschland funktionieren würde also sie
sehen es gibt viel zu tun und gerade
wenn man für den Bereich zuständig ist
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend da
geht einem die Arbeit nicht aus da
wünsche ich mir ganz ganz viel
Engagement ich liebe Titel
wir sind als an und als Union an Ihrer
Seite wenn sinnvoll ist und nicht von
allem anderen sind wir eine konstruktive
Opposition und wir werden so eine gute
Arbeit machen dass wir in vier Jahren
hier auch wieder als Regierungspartei
stehen vielen Dank
Dorothee Bär war das hat die
Bundesfamilienministerin Anne Spiegel
hier auch direkt angesprochen die von
der Bank der Bundesregierung aus hier
die Reden verfolgt auch hier die debat
in der Debatte schon gesprochen hat
Ulrike Bahr spricht jetzt die
Vorsitzende im Ausschuss für Familien
Senioren Frauen und Jugend und Mitglied
der SPD-Fraktion
die auf dem dunklen bleibt obwohl sie
zahlenmäßig im Rampenlicht stehen müsste
ich rede von den älteren Frauen etwa
13,2 Millionen Frauen im Alter über 60
in Deutschland
natürlich sind ihre Lebenswege und damit
auch ihre Lebenssituationen im Alter
sehr unterschiedlich und zum Glück
erleben wir dass sich der Blick der
Gesellschaft auf ältere Frauen
allmählich wandelt während früher z.B
Schauspielerinnen jenseits der 40
einfach von den Leinwänden verschwanden
sind ältere Frauen heute im Kino und
Film wesentlich prominenter vertreten
ich erinnere z.B an die großartige
kleine und grauhaarige Judy Dench die
2012 mit damals Mitte 70 große Erfolge
als weibliche Hauptrolle im James Bond
Film Skyfall
aber das Leben ist kein Kinofilm die
Lebensrealität der meisten älteren
Frauen in Deutschland sieht leider
anders aus gerade ältere Frauen müssen
ausbaden was vor allem in der Bonner
Republik versäumt wurde sie wurden oft
nicht so beruflichen Karrieren ermutigt
sie wurden schlecht bezahlte Berufe oder
auch in Minijobs abgedrängt und müssen
jetzt in der Folge mit sehr kleinen
Renten leben
die Grundrente hat vielen von ihnen
geholfen im Schnitt erhalten die
Berechtigten Frauen 37% mehr Rente aber
dennoch sind Restaurant und Kinobesuch
oder eine neue Brille keine
Selbstverständlichkeiten der Gender
Pension GAP liegt immer noch bei knapp
60%, und keinem anderen europäischen
Industrieland ist er größer liebe
Kollegen Kolleginnen die Altersarmut in
Deutschland ist weiblich Frauen sind
zusätzlich noch im Rentenalter sehr
stark mit kehrarbeit belastet die Kinder
mögen aus dem Haus sein aber sehr viele
übernehmen in diesem Alter
Pflegetätigkeiten sogenannte junge
Seniorinnen sind die größte Gruppe bei
den pflegenden Angehörigen die beiden
letzten Jahre der Pandemie waren eine
gewaltige Belastung Tagespflegen waren
geschlossen Pflegedienste konnten nicht
kommen Beratungsstellen war nur
eingeschränkt zugänglich mit diesen
zusätzlichen pflegebelastungen hatten
und haben vor allem Frauen zu kämpfen
lassen Sie uns deshalb beim
Internationalen Frauentag auch die
Frauen in den Blick nehmen die von 9
gleichstellungspolitischen Initiativen
nicht mehr direkt profitieren können Sie
profitieren aber sehr wohl von einer
guten sozialen Infrastruktur
funktionierenden Unterstützungssystemen
für pflegende Angehörige
Mehrgenerationenhäusern und Angeboten zu
Überwindung von Einsamkeit und Isolation
das muss das Ziel sein und daran
arbeiten wir gemeinsam als Koalition
aus diesem Grund streben wir eine
umfassende Förderung seniorengerechter
Ansätze an für mehr Partizipation
Engagement Alltagshilfen sowie Bildungs-
und begegnungsangeboten all das verdient
unser aller Unterstützung gerade mit
Blick auf die Frauen 60+ vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin war
[Applaus]
als letzte
kollemeier SPD-Fraktion
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Frau
Ministerin Spiegel seit der
Internationale Frauentag an den wir
heute denken die ersten paar Tagen sein
wird und deshalb habe ich gedacht das
war auch noch mal ein kleiner Blick aufs
internationale werfen habe lange
überlegt was ich zu Afghanistan sage
aber da hätten meine drei Minuten nicht
gereicht ich habe jetzt gedacht ich gehe
jetzt 100 km weiter östlich und lande
mal dann in Polen von uns aus erreichbar
in anderthalb Stunden mit dem Auto und
ich schaue mir den 21 Dezember letzten
Jahres an als die 37-Jährige Agnieszka
Mutter von drei Kindern schwanger mit
Zwillingen ins Krankenhaus mit dem
wunderbaren Namen zur heiligen Jungfrau
Maria in in
Stockau eingeliefert wurde
sage später Staub ein Fötus ihre beiden
Zwillinge die sie im Bauch hatte und die
Ärzte dieser Klinik weigerten sich sie
zu operieren wegen des restriktiven
abtreibungsrechts in Polen
eine Woche später starb der zweite Fötus
weitere 2 Tage lang haben sich die Ärzte
geweigert die Frau zu operieren das
haben sie denn nach zwei Tagen gemacht
derweil war dann die die sept sich so
weit fortgeschritten dass diese Mutter
von drei Kindern am 25 Januar diesen
Jahres starb jetzt können wir hier wohl
Feile Reden halten von Solidarität mit
den Frauen in Polen und das meine ich
auch aus tiefstem Herzen aber ich glaube
was wir hier machen können was wir
deutsches Parlament machen können ist
unsere eigenen Hausaufgaben zu machen
und uns nicht beeindrucken zu lassen vor
denen die auch bei uns in restriktivere
schwangerschaftsrecht wollen und alles
was wir an Fortschritten verabredet
haben boykottieren wollen und deshalb
bin ich froh dass wir auch für die
Frauen in Polen aber auch für die Frauen
in Europa aber auch für die Frauen in
Deutschland den 219a jetzt streichen und
das ist aber noch nicht
wir haben wir Frauen in Deutschland
gehabt hat dass wir bevormundet und
gegängelt werden
und dann immer unter dem Deckmäntelchen
dem Schutz des ungeborenen Lebens das
sind nur dazu die Frauen Zugängen und
wir schützen bei uns kein ungeborenes
Leben indem wir den Frauen Strafe
androhen wir schützen dann ungeborenes
Leben wenn wir ausreichend Wohnheim zur
Verfügung stellen wir schützen
ungeborenes Leben wenn wir ordentliche
gut bezahlte Arbeitsplätze zur Verfügung
stellen wir schützen ungeborenes Leben
wenn meine partnerschaftliche Teilung
der Familienarbeit haben wir schützen
ungewohntes Leben mit den Scheiden
Mindestlohn das ist das was wir brauchen
und deshalb müssen wir in die Debatte
gehen ohne Chance hat gesagt was machen
wir eigentlich da im Strafrecht aber wir
müssen dann auch noch weitergehen
kostenlose Verhütungsmittel und so
weiter jetzt leuchtet der Herr Präsident
mich schon an und deshalb komme ich
jetzt zum Schluss und sage meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Gleichstellung der Geschlechter ist die
Haupt Demokratie und nicht der Nachtisch
herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin in der Tat hat
die Elektronik sie eingeleuchtet aber
ich habe sie auch angeleuchtet von
hinten bei ihren Ausführungen
damit schließe ich die Aussprache